et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés il y a de l'imam directeur du
mensuel Afrique Magazine bonjour Yann
bonsoir
actuellement sur la question de la forêt
en Afrique un l'un des poumons de la
planète le deuxième après l'Amazonie
peut-être à terme le premier et puis
également sur ce phénomène qui a
rencontré d'ailleurs Emmanuel Macron
lors de sa vie 10 en Algérie DJ Snake
également avec nous Bruno Darroux
chroniqueur international à la France 24
bonjour Bruno bonjour Raphaël il y
aura-t-il de la neige à Noël la question
rituel ne tient plus pour une fois de
l'espoir mais bel et bien de la crainte
en Europe et si nous avions tous froid
incapable de nous chauffer correctement
depuis les derniers rebondissements de
la guerre en Ukraine c'est devenu un
enjeu incontournable celui d'éventuels
coupures de courant et autres pénuries
d'énergie Elisabeth borne la chef du
gouvernement y est revenu aujourd'hui au
détour de son exposé des mesures à
prendre pour la France cet hiver écoutez
seul la sobriété et la solidarité
européenne nous permettront d'éviter des
coupures et des rationnements dans les
cas de figure les plus pessimistes comme
un hiver particulièrement froid cumulé à
des difficultés d'approvisionnement
ces scénarios nous incitent à poursuivre
notre stratégie une sobriété choisie
plutôt que des coupures subies une
solidarité européenne pour mieux
résister à l'hiver voilà on reviendra
sur les mesures proposées par Elisabeth
Bank dans le détail mais il a dit même
on sent monter la crainte de coupure
d'électricité et non plus seulement
d'une flambée des factures
les deux
flambées des factures parce que les gens
le sentent il y a le bouclier hier non
ce que je trouve
il y a le temps court le temps court il
est très très politique donc il faut que
le gouvernement rassure rassure les
citoyens en leur disant voilà ça va pas
être totalement catastrophique je pense
aussi qu'il y a une part de j'ose pas le
dire mais de semi dramatisation pour que
les gens s'imprègnent bien du problème
qu'on fasse attention qu'on fasse la
sobriété etc la deuxième chose c'est que
ça doit rentrer dans un cadre et et là
je trouve que le discours politique
manque un peu de d'élargissement
si on peut survenir ça rentre dans le
cadre d'une guerre économique et
commerciale ouverte entre l'Union
européenne et la Russie dans le cadre
d'un conflit militaire entre la Russie
et l'Ukraine dans le cas d'un conflit
militaire dans lequel nous on est engagé
et donc c'est parti pour durer cet hiver
prochain etc et donc c'est aussi
là on parle de est-ce qu'on va couper le
chauffage au mois de novembre mais le
mois de novembre prochain on sera dans
les mêmes discussions parce qu'il y a un
espèce de shift
systémique complet de l'Union européenne
dans sa relation énergétique à la Russie
qui va falloir trouver du gaz ailleurs
qu'il va falloir trouver du pétrole
ailleurs qui va falloir aller le
chercher en Algérie qu'il va falloir se
faire le Qatar peut-être en Iran
peut-être que les Américains vont nous
aider et la deuxième chose
là aussi je trouve que le discours
politique est très court termiste c'est
qu'il se passe une espèce de ça
redynamisé les mécanismes de l'Union
européenne entre elles à l'intérieur
d'elle-même avec les avec les
perspectives de compensation entre
l'Allemagne et la France avec la
perspective que les Espagnols qui ont
des ports GNL etc que les filles et que
beaucoup de pays sont en train de
construire des gnelles et donc des ports
des ports pour importer du gaz liquide
et donc il se passe quelque chose en
Europe qui est lié à cette guerre j'ai
lu aujourd'hui un des quotidiens qui
décide avait pas eu la guerre on a eu
droit à un discours absolument
l'unifiant de everetting is good azur ou
pas goût des yeux joueurs etc et là on a
quand même au Parlement européen un
discours sur la construction d'une
Europe plus unie face à un ennemi
stratégique qui est maintenant voilà
c'est c'est la situation dans laquelle
on est alors d'ici à ce grand
basculement vous nous décrivez vers
l'Ouest et le Sud via non plus donc des
pipelines mais effectivement des
terminaux qui permettront de de
d'importer du gaz naturel et les
mutations et les mutations énergie
durable propre etc qui vont être boostés
pour mais qui prendront elle aussi du
temps le remède à court terme vanté par
Elisabeth borne c'est effectivement la
solidarité européenne et puis cette
sobriété qu'elle incarne presque
physiquement Bruno oui dans son style ça
je vous le conseille à l'incarne la
sobriété mais oui c'est un retour un peu
la solidarité européenne pour poursuivre
un peu sur ce que disaitiade aussi en
fait l'Europe finalement revient un peu
aux origines parce que finalement
l'Europe elle s'est construit dans les
années 50 c'était la CECA la Communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier donc
à l'origine ça a commencé par une mise
en commun de politique énergétique puis
peu à peu on a on a oublié tout ça et
c'est vrai que c'est un peu à cause de
vladivia Poutine que l'Europe est
obligée de réagir effectivement de
commencer à changer de logiciel alors
après dans le discours donc cela fait
Merlin il faut aussi noter que cette
sobriété et cette solidarité elle passe
quand même mais on verra comment ce sera
mis en œuvre par une taxation alors on
va le voir justement un plafonnement
notamment sur ceux qui produisent des
énergies renouvelables et du nucléaire
le chiffre avancé par Ossola faderlion
est considérable
mais en tout cas la France elle entend
bien montrer l'exemple de ces échanges
puisqu'on on évoque même des des
exportations de gaz de la France vers
l'Allemagne et le mois d'octobre oui
enfin ça marche j'en ai deux sens parce
que l'Allemagne vendra aussi
l'électricité à la France donc on va
chacun vend ce qu'il veut c'est la mise
en oeuvre d'une solidarité européenne
concrète et de ce point de vue là
effectivement c'est un changement par
rapport à ce qu'on avait connu quand
même ces dernières années à cause
effectivement de cette comme le disait
Ziad de cette situation stratégique qui
a radicalement changé alors comme vous
le disiez vous pour le coup aussi Bruno
à l'instant on sous la vendeur layonne
elle est longuement revenue
effectivement sur sa stratégie en
matière d'énergie pour son troisième
discours sur l'état de l'Union inspiré
d'ailleurs d'une coutume qui a qui a
cours de longue date aux États-Unis et
bien la trouver pour l'occasion des
accents presque socialistes écoutez
des millions d'Européens ont besoin
d'aide en ces temps les profits doivent
être partagés et distribués à ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin
les entreprises productrices d'énergie
fossiles vont devoir payer une
contribution de crise en tout nos
propositions vont permettre de lever 140
milliards d'euros afin de permettre aux
pays membres de supporter au mieux cette
situation
les élus de la nuque ici en France
syntaxe les super profits des gens du
pétrole et du gaz Mélenchon arriver
vendeur lion Lefebvre
je pense que sur le fond sur le principe
c'est nul c'est tout c'est tout le monde
c'est à dire vous faites des profits
surréalistes beaucoup n'ont pas
particulièrement changé donc vous pouvez
pas juste vous enrichir à cause de le
problème c'est que la mise en oeuvre de
ce genre de mécanisme est très complexe
d'abord toutes les entreprises qui
fournissent du gaz ou du pétrole ne sont
pas européennes en prenant déjà rien que
les Anglais qui sont hors Europe
comment on peut accentuer comment on
peut organiser ça comment on peut dire
au Qatar ou Abu Dhabi à votre pétrole
vous savez il est à ça comment on va le
mettre donc je pense que c'est un débat
très politique intéressant
dont on ne je crois pas qu'on est encore
bien mesuré les implications techniques
et financières du mécanisme et la
deuxième chose c'est que là on est
vraiment dans une discussion européenne
ça se passe à Strasbourg mais ce
problème il est planétaire c'est-à-dire
vous avez des pays aujourd'hui en
particulier en Afrique qui subventionne
directement le prix du fioul et du
pétrole pour pas que ça pète je parle
vraiment au sens social les sociétales
pas que ça saute et donc c'est ces
pays-là sont en train de subventionner
avec de l'argent qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément et donc ces mécanismes à coup
de déficits publics
c'est soit le soit les consommateurs
soit l'état soit la société de raffinage
cachette du mais en tous les cas on sent
que les tensions s'accumulent un petit
peu partout sur la planète sur cette
question énergétique et donc là aussi je
trouve que le discours européen encore
une fois on fait face à une urgence il
faut persuader les Européens de tenir
dans la guerre mais il faut aussi
expliquer que c'est c'est quelque chose
de nettement plus global et je pense que
les Russes jouent sur cet aspect là
parce que s'ils peuvent fournir du gaz
ou du pétrole ou aider ou ceci ou cela a
des prix
moins moins
cher ça peut être une arme politique je
juste pour préciser effectivement là où
ça paraît un peu plus crédible un peu
plus concret c'est ce qu'elle a dit
aussi quand elle parlait de ceux qui
produisent de l'énergie nucléaire ou des
énergies renouvelables parce que là sans
doute après faudra voir comment
concrètement ça se met en place mais par
rapport au producteur de d'énergie
fossile plafonner les revues de ceux qui
produisent du nucléaire ou du
renouvelable ça paraît plus facile à
mettre en œuvre à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne mais il faudra voir comment
on passe de l'échelon européen à
l'exploitation nationale et les champs
locales et comment concrètement à un
moment de consommateur son parce que
l'idée ce serait de faire de la
redistribution en
prenant en quelque sorte c'est super
profit pour aider au niveau de l'Europe
d'après ce qu'elle dit rien les ménages
les plus modestes et c'est dire si cette
problématique touche bien tous les
Européens pas seulement les Français
israéliens presque mieux lotis les
français si l'on en quoi Élisabeth borne
écoutez la retenir sur le bouclier
tarifaire cette forme d'assurance sur
les prix bien françaises qu'elle entend
prolonger jusqu'à l'année prochaine
nous allons prolonger en 2023 le
mécanisme de bouclier tarifaire pour
tous les ménages pour les copropriétés
les logements sociaux les petites
entreprises et les plus petites communes
nous allons ainsi limiter les hausses de
prix à 15% pour le gaz en janvier 2023
et à 15% pour l'électricité en février
15% au lieu de
120%, c'est l'engagement que nous
prenons
[Musique]
de constater que le ce bouclier
tarifaire nouvelle version par rapport
premier Bouclier tarifaire qui limitait
à 4% déjà on est plus dans la même
échelle il y a une forme de recul du
bouquet tarifaire et pour certains
ménages même si un chèque énergie pour
les 12 millions de ménages les plus
modestes en France à la fin de l'année
ça va quand même être très difficile
lieu juste un dernier mot et puis on
passera l'autre sujet mais c'est quand
même important parce que la mandalaya
nous dit l'Union européenne va engager
une réforme complète du marché
électricité l'idée en fait c'est de
découpler le prix de l'électricité de
celui du gaz pour pouvoir notamment
bénéficier des énergies renouvelables à
bas coût à leur vrai prix finalement et
non plus indexer sur le gaz bien sûr à
commencer pour les Français par le
nucléaire c'est essentiel ça parce que
pourquoi ça a pas été fait finalement
pourquoi on continue à payer
l'électricité dérivée du nucléaire
indexées sur du gaz moi j'ai pas fait un
DEA en énergie diverses mais je pense
qu'avant on n'était pas d'abord on était
régulé par le marché absolument
avec ses excès et ses qualités
deuxièmement on avait du gaz cadeau ou
presque arrivé par des pipelines et donc
on se posait pas la question donc c'est
pour ça c'est pour ça qu'il faut parler
de changement systémique c'est-à-dire
que en quelques mois et c'est là aussi
que je pense que le Paris russe est
quand même complexe c'est-à-dire que
normalement on aurait du sentir un
espèce d'effondrement en disant au
secours comment faire bah non on n'est
pas dans le au secours comment on va
faire on est dans le partage comment je
tourne comment tu m'en donnes comment
l'État français accepte de dépenser 2
milliards de plus mais comme vous disiez
tous les deux de toute façon par rapport
aux centaines de milliards qu'on a
dépensé depuis trois ans ça prouve aussi
et encore une fois je suis pas un
spécialiste à 100% mais ça prouve aussi
que les marchés financiers de lâchent
pas c'est à dire qu'on pense qu'il y a
une capacité de résistance européenne
qui est là et donc c'est ça qui bouge
c'est ça qui change après
il y a des mécanismes financiers j'ai
découvert un petit peu il faut couvrir
ses achats d'énergie il faut couvrir ces
achats de la base six mois à l'avance
faut faire des avances en trésorerie
tous ces trucs qui ont été inventés pour
les traders pour tout ça va peut-être
changer aussi et la souveraineté
énergétique on s'en foutait complètement
le sujet l'Afrique le Moyen-Orient la
Russie tout ça allait nous financer
notre développement même s'il fallait un
peu payer bon ça a changé ça a changé et
tu as changé aussi en parlant un peu sa
chambre d'un rebond de la de la volonté
de souveraineté européenne en fait c'est
que sur la semaine dernière on en a pas
parlé là mais très rapidement quand même
elle a parlé des terres rares du lithium
60% par la Chine il faut qu'on fasse des
stocks il faut qu'on fasse comme les
américains qu'on fasse des grosses
stocks qu'on maîtrise mieux les
histoires de raffinage etc chacun pour
soi et pas chacun pour soi peut-être la
naissance du nouvel Europe 1 de non plus
du charbon et de l'acier mais du lithium
et d'uranium
c'était aujourd'hui aussi à Londres la
procession du cercueil de la Reine
Elizabeth de bucking a voulu réclamer
vous l'aurez de Buckingham vers
Westminster hollow auront lieu les
funérailles lundi prochain événement
suivi d'ailleurs pour France 24 par
Bruno Darou ici même à mes côtés mais
écoutez d'abord quelques-uns des
témoignages des Britanniques présents
sur place le long du cortège je me suis
positionné ici hier dès 6h j'ai pris un
sac avec moi et je n'ai plus bougé je
suis chanceux je ne pensais pas avoir
une place en première ligne
on avait assisté au couronnement
d'Elizabeth on avait fait à cette époque
le déplacement jusqu'à Londres pour voir
les décorations depuis la reine avait
été notre pilier c'était une femme
extraordinaire
c'est la fin du nerf Charles III fera un
excellent roi mais c'est une nouvelle
ère qui s'ouvre on fait nos adieux à
celle de la reine
une ferveur qui ne se dément pas Bruno
oui il y a une vraie ferveur si on peut
pas le nier depuis une fatigue
mais même en Grande-Bretagne moi j'ai
entendu des reportages ou certains
britanniques disent quand même un ça
dure un peu trop longtemps et deux ça
coûte très très cher tout se faste parce
que évidemment ce genre de cérémonie
quand même coûte de l'argent à un moment
ou à cause de l'inflation c'est enfin la
session politique économique et sociale
est très compliqué où les gens se
demandent s'ils vont pouvoir terminer
des fins de mois bon tout n'est quand
même pas aussi unanimiste que ce qu'on
vient d'entendre mais il y a une vraie
ferveur populaire avec la question qui
nous nous interpelle un peu qui sommes
sur un autre système démocratique de
dire bah finalement ce système qui nous
paraissait un peu
suranné etc cette espèce d'équilibre une
monarchie qui incarne la pérennité et à
côté à une démocratie mais où finalement
les choses changent ou c'est un peu
chaotique parfois mais c'est pas si
grave parce que l'Europe comme ils
disent et là bah finalement ça marche
pas si mal dans le cas de la
Grande-Bretagne cela dit le roi Charles
III qui incarne l'unité lui souhaite bon
courage parce que vu l'état du royaume
ça va pas être facile vous êtes c'est un
autre aspect du bilan royal dont vous
vouliez parler celui de la
décolonisation au sein de l'Empire
britannique celui où le soleil ne se
couche jamais à une réalité bien souvent
très éloignée pour les populations
émancipées du conte de fée que tente
encore un carnet aujourd'hui comme un
welve non parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que la monarchie
masque tout c'est à dire c'est le conte
de fée elle est elle a un parcours
personnel moi je reconnais une histoire
de vie je suis un fan de Crown sur
Netflix elle a une histoire incroyable
avec assez bas c'est une sacrée une
sacrée reine après ce que ça va tenir
mais par contre cette monarchie ça
permet de masquer à certains nombre de
choses et en particulier elle a vécu
elle a été la monarque de la
décolonisation et contrairement à une
espèce de légende ou de réputation qui
s'est installée la décolonisation
britannique n'a pas été nettement
meilleur et nettement moins sanglante
que la décolonisation française voire
dans certains cas nettement plus
sanglante il y a eu des massacres en
Inde et il suffit de regarder encore une
fois une référence de film d'athenburros
Gandhi pour voir à quel point ça a été
brutal il faut voir ce qui s'est passé
au Kenya il faut voir ce qui s'est passé
en Afrique du Sud quand même l'Afrique
du Sud celle des celle de l'apartheid
c'est les Hollandais enfin c'est les
c'est les c'est les descendants des
Hollandais à les africaneurs mais c'est
aussi les Anglais le cap était une des
villes les plus ségréguées d'Afrique du
Sud et donc tous ces héritage là de
l'Angleterre impériale et on pourrait
citer d'autres choses on pourrait citer
voilà et donc on voit apparaître dans la
discussion y en Angleterre dans les
grands quotidiens etc on commence à voir
apparaître un débat sur cette période
que
sa classe ça fraîcheur on va dire je
parle pas de même la danse avec un
chroma d'une certaine manière peut être
interprété de plusieurs manières je veux
pas revenir à de craindre pour il y a
une interprétation dans de grandes qui
est nettement plus cynique mais voilà
donc il faut pas oublier que cette reine
a vécu la décolonisation et elle a vécu
aussi la sortie de l'Europe elle a vécu
aussi tous ces facteurs qui sont des
facteurs de rétrécissement de l'Union et
peut-être que toutes ces émotion c'est
aussi mon Dieu mon Dieu si on pouvait
avoir encore nostalgie quoi cette
nostalgie de l'Empire merci beaucoup
j'ai dit merci à Bruno Darou d'avoir été
avec nous c'est la fin dont on va plus
loin on se retrouve dans deux minutes
pour un nouveau journal d'en parler à
Christ avec nous